in the opening moments of halo
infinite's campaign a despondent pilot
says to master chief you have one bullet
against an entire army what can you do
on your own
chief with all the stoicism that fans
have come to love him for replies in
that iconic gravelly voice it's enough
[Music]
after a couple of lackluster entries
i've been feeling less and less drawn to
the halo franchise so it was difficult
not to read into that moment for me once
a die hard fan halo infinite feels like
developer 343 industries last shot at
reinvigorating my fandom and based on
what i've played of the campaign it
might just be enough
wow look at this place it's so
full of more monsters coming to kill us
halo infinite sets up the drama of its
narrative by placing the story in the
shadow of master chief's failure which
is laid bare when he's discovered and
thought out by the aforementioned pilot
while chief floated through space
cryogenically frozen the banish carved a
bloody war path through the unsc's
forces for all intents and purposes the
fight is finished and the banished are
on the cost for victory the death blood
will be dealt to humanity when they
secure control over zeta halo it's in
this state of affairs and what chief
represents within it that i found myself
starting to remember why i love this
franchise and character so much the as
of yet unnamed pilot represents the
reality of the world halo infinite takes
place in he has lost much and his
desperation to survive and return to
whatever semblance of home remains for
him is evident at every opportunity the
pilot implores chief to walk the other
way when battle approaches the pilot
doesn't see victory as a possibility
only more death and destruction but as
before chief is once again that voice of
hope his fight to save humanity begins
with a tumble through space weaving
through a wreckage as he scavenges
whatever guns and ammo he can find to
give himself a fighting chance as he
does somber piano keys play and it feels
like the return of a hero who is
throwing himself at impossible odds just
because it's his duty admittedly this
sounds pretty much like every other halo
title in existence but what
distinguishes infinite is that this
narrative setup and the emotional weight
it trades off is supported by the
gameplay
the first three missions of infinite's
campaign are classical halo affairs it
feels familiar and comfortable the way
you might feel while fighting through a
set piece in one of the first three halo
games the fact that infinite begins by
successfully evoking those games is to
me a great sign these missions are a
display of stunning sci-fi architecture
in which you battle through tight
corridors frantically gunning down
scurrying grunts who squeal in that
comedic way they do eventually emerging
into more open rooms where you can slip
behind cover and leap around as you
trade head-on blows with brutes or try
to stick trixie elites with grenades
it's that classic halo gameplay that
begins with a single shot and before you
know it you've gunfired grenaded and
meleed your way through dozens of
enemies and cleared out a room smooth
scrappy and also satisfying
much of these first few missions is
spent setting the stage for the story
without spoiling anything and because i
don't know exactly where it's going and
how it'll pan out cortana still has an
important part to play in the narrative
gone though she supposedly may be her
presence is weaved into what happens in
a way that gives her that kind of
invisible hand guiding events feel
though it's early there are also hints
at grappling with themes of mortality
legacy and responsibility which is an
exciting prospect for a franchise as
storied as halo where infinite truly
came into his own at least in the first
few hours i played it was when it let
chief loose in the open world
here changes made to the halo gameplay
framework that felt awkward in previous
games felt more at home in this new one
the setup is simple and i dare say
overly familiar given the prevalence of
open world action games but within the
context of halo it feels fresh and
exciting chief is dropped onto zeta halo
and a few markers are placed on the map
some lead to the main mission that will
progress story while others allow you to
help out unsc soldiers who have found
themselves in the spot of bother oh no
it looks like there are multiple unsc
squads engaged in
trying to survive
they need your help chief there are high
value members of the banished army that
you can attempt to take out or spartan
calls you can track down and use towards
improving your equipment in the time i
had i was able to improve the cooldown
on the grapple shot and even give it the
ability to stun enemies briefly
there are also options to improve the
performance of my shield with other
equipment and upgrades clearly also yet
to be discovered also dotted around the
map are forward operating bases that
have been overrun by banished by wiping
out the occupying forces here chief can
take them back and allow unsc forces to
establish a stronghold doing this is
incredibly satisfying because it allows
you as legendary super soldier master
chief to descend upon unsuspecting
enemies and lay waste to them
expertly picking them off one by one in
a hail of bullets and bombs these
enemies react to your presence some
running away in terror others brazenly
attempting to hold their ground these
fob missions felt like big battles but
in contained locations within a larger
open world the enemies didn't feel like
pushovers and i often found myself with
my back up against the wall this is
where the grapple shot which allows
chief to hook onto surfaces and propel
himself came into play and it's a
genuine game changer for halo even in
the little time i have spent with the
game i can't see myself playing another
halo without it
the grapple shot brings a sense of
dynamism to the halo combat experience
that has been so sorely missing amid
shooters like call of duty battlefield
apex and others which are more energetic
contemporaries the grappler shot also
introduces strategic considerations that
just didn't exist before letting chief
pull items and objects and environments
to him whether that's a gun or an
explosive canister it also allows him to
latch onto enemies and quickly close the
distance to deliver a crushing melee
attack right to their face and then
swing into the air and out of sight just
as quickly
with the grapple shot there's a sense of
dominance you can exert over the
battlefield that feels genuinely
exhilarating and even out of combat
moving around the vast open world is
made all the more enjoyable bride of the
grapple shot i was able to scale
cliffsides with ease and leap from
ridiculous heights and land safely
simply by grappling at the last moment
at times i felt like a pebble skimming
across the top of water and it was a
delight these elements alone bode well
for the open world format moving around
zeta halo with the grapple show and then
descending upon entrenched spanish to
clear out fobs alone feels like it could
be a great new addition to the halo
formula and one that modernizes a
franchise that for me has been
struggling to find a comfortable new
groove to work within in the post bungie
era
but i think the broader implication of
what the open world and the various
missions offered within it represent is
way more exciting for me the first few
missions of infinite felt like 343
saying it knows that it has some work to
do still that it needs to prove that
halo and master chief still have what it
takes and that is exactly what it feels
like this game is about unlike the last
few games in the series halo infinite
doesn't just want to say master chief is
a legendary spartan it wants you to
prove it
welcome back
you